since your forte is to talk politics
which presidential candidate do you feel
is most beneficial for filmmakers and
artists oh that's which ones better for
filmmakers or artists entrepreneurs of
the two they're running I I think that
because most these filmmakers lean left
they would have more fun with a with a
mitt romney presidency because they just
would it would be a more fun for them to
criticize they're not going to criticize
a boy Barry Obama is their guy they love
them so it's hard for them because they
very few of them can see the flawless or
can you know kind of a funny santa male
live that's what they do they have to
stomach they have to the last time I saw
the entertainment industry do a great
job making fun of a president was a phil
hartman doing Bill Clinton and that was
he did a great job but for some reason I
don't think that there's just the kind
of heart behind mocking Obama as there
was the bush and let's face it out was
it does it will ferrell did a great bush
he said imitate him the bush-gore
debates in two thousand or some of
saturday lives best fits and i can laugh
at my guy so I don't have a problem but
I don't know that that the left can
really laughs it Barack Obama it just
supposing medicine to humor about this
guy needs I don't know that he's that
funny to imitate so I think that have
more fun with MIT with a whole you know
well thing and making it kind of a
character of him being this evil
corporate guy so which President though
do you think will be most beneficial to
artists entrepreneurs in terms of
helping them further their careers well
look the surface answer is that with a
more liberal president
going to have more artistic freedom over
the fact of the matter is I don't think
it matters the masses want to be
entertained it doesn't matter who's in
the White House I found it amusing
though over the past few years hearing a
few celebrities scream bloody murder
about the taxes wanna came to mind was
Lady Gaga you know she went from
wherever she was at I don't know what
she was making before I don't know a lot
about her story that she did come out
and complain about taxes a lot of these
famous people who typically will talk
about being for the poor and whatnot
they're all one percenters and so I
don't think that it really has much been
impact on it I think that most of the
financial impact on the movie business
is not on the federal level is probably
the state and city level so I don't
think it's going to make a difference if
you're talented you entertain the people
you're going to do well
you